So,
what you do is you create your own curriculum that is above and beyond what is
handed to you. And I think, you know, I think about what was handed to me,
education wise and how I kind of blew it. And I talk about that in the book,
there's a whole chapter on creating your own curriculum.
It was based on a tweet. This guy did,
Frank Fleming said that if you actually took all the education time, 16,
like 16 years of education and kind of curated what you wanted to do,
you would be Batman 16 years of like martial arts,
philosophy languages you would be, or economics, you would be Batman,
but instead you have 16 years of education and you're applying for jobs,
you know, in pharmaceutical sales. And you're hoping you will get that job.
It's got, look, you wrote a book, you wrote a book here.
This is what your 27th book. How many books now? Yeah.
Yes. This is book number nine or blight. What I like to say?
Yeah. I like to say it's eight more than yours. Dave.
Eight more books than yours. I can't even see your first book. It's so early.
It's like, call me when you're on your fifth book.
Well,
then I can get the patches on my elbows and the whole thing and be an esteemed.
Right?
Thank you. You'll be like Judd, Hirsch and ordinary people.
You are going into your sort of J D Salinger phase though of life.
I can tell because you've got your house in the undisclosed location in the
woods. You occasionally tweet pictures. You're on a Lake,
surrounded by trees and things. You're sort of going into that.
You're thought of as a, as a cable news guy,
but you're what really drives you is the desire to be off the grid,
hidden in the woods. True or false.
I, I believe that I was self distancing before it was cool. I,
um, I don't know what it was. It was because I was younger. I was more social,
but I have no desire. Like, you know, when you're in New York,
it is impossible to even get me out of my apartment. You know?
Literally you end up, yes. You come to my,
I made you come to my apartment when it was destroyed,
because I would rather sit in my apartment that had just been flooded that
actually like, Oh, the is, go meet me at this restaurant. I go, you know,
I don't really feel like, but I.
I am. I'm like, I'm like Greg named the restaurant. It's on me,
whatever you want, you know, grass fed this. You're like,
could you just come to my place? I have, I have one beer.
Yes. I'm not that bad. I always have booze,
but we did go to Del Frisco's. Remember we did that across the hall.
Who was that? That was nice. Um.
Nice guy. Yeah. So it was your brother, right?
That you told me that was your brother. Yeah. Okay.
It was my brother. He says, he's my brother. I'm not sure.
No, but let, let's talk about, uh, the, the quarantine stuff a little bit.
Cause, cause in your book, you actually, you,
I guess you added the preface after you wrote the whole thing,
because then you want it to address the quality and stuff and they,
they let you gamut it in there.
Yeah, it was interesting because we had to have a discussion,
whether something in the news ends up branding your book or should your book be
above it all. So I'm, I'm,
I'm the book's going to bed and all this stuff is happening.
And the book itself is about a collective response to crap in your life so that
we all share the risk and be better people.
And this thing is happening and I'm going, I have,
this has to go in the book because all of the things in the book,
the collective response prison to two ideas, unbending minds, uh,
blaming and forgiveness, all fit.
You could all point all of these tips in that direction. And um,
but there was like, there were people going leaking. Yeah.
But you don't want to be a pandemic book. And I go, well, you know what,
if this book had come out in 2016, we would be talking about the Trump election.
If it'd been coming out in 12 2012, it would be Obama, you know, or,
or if it came out in 2001, it would be nine 11.
So you can't ignore reality.
So I put it in there and it in, in, um, it's weird a lot,
all the chapters in this book are details are,
are dealing with crap that happened later.
Like even the riots in the oldest looks, I talk about social media.
I talk about, uh, uh, marginalization, demonization, all this stuff.
And it's like, everything is happening. And it makes, I, I it's,
it kind of scares me because I'm trying to be positive.
And the book is trying to be positive,
but we're in a time where we're not sure if we can be positive anymore,
you know? No.
Well, nobody's, nobody's sure of anything, but I will go on the record.
Gutfeld is saying that if anyone watching this enjoy don't burn this book,
they will dig the plus because actually a lot of, a lot of the themes, I mean,
this is why we do so much stuff together lately.
A lot of the themes that both of us care about related to free speech,
what's happening at the colleges,
trying to keep some semblance of Western society, organized,
maintaining a sense of humor through it,
all that that really is what the thrust of this is about. But on the,
on the self-help side,
do you sense that people over the last four months that there's going to be
like, when, when this thing is done, if it's, if it's ever done that,
that there will be a real split where it'll be like,
some people really will have gotten their lives in order and lost weight,
how to cook, started new hobbies, et cetera, et cetera.
And then there will be this other set of people that will just like completely
lost control of their lives.
And I know both sides of that, of that equation.
It's kind of like the it's like the education argument that like you could just
go to high school, check in and check out and you'd come out worse.
Or you can be that kid that goes, Oh, I want to do this. I want to go,
I'm going to, I'm going to be like the Dana Perino,
I'm going to join the speech and debate club because that's going to make me
better and I'm going to, and then I'm going to go play bad, uh,
with field hockey. I'm trying to think of sports, but I mean, it's like,
it's like lacrosse create lacrosse. Thank you.
So what you do is you create your curriculum that is above and beyond what, uh,
is handed to you. And I think, you know, I think about what was handed to me,
education wise and how I kind of blew it. And I talk about that in the book,
there's a whole chapter on creating your own curriculum.
It was based on a tweet. This guy did,
Frank Fleming said that if you actually took all the education time, 16,
like 16 years of education and kind of curated what you wanted to do,
you would be Batman 16 years of like martial arts
philosophy languages you would be, or economics, you would be Batman,
but instead you have 16 years of education and you're applying for jobs,
you know, in pharmaceutical sales.
And you're hoping you will get that job because you did not think about it.
Like what an incredible opportunity.
So that's how I started thinking about the pandemic is like, okay,
the cards that are being dealt are limiting everything.
Like I can't go to the gym, which I've been going for 40 years, I guess,
to the gym, like every week for 40 years.
And that's over and I know how much I eat. I eat a buttload of food,
so this is not going to end well for me also, I tend to, you know,
I like drinking and I'm going to be home a lot. And there's also,
all of these variables are pointing in a terrible direction for me.
And I thought, well,
what if I decided to create like a S a S quote,
Scott Adams, uh, system, uh, rather than goals.
And so I like cut out the, get cut out the, the starches and the,
and the carbohydrates. And then, and then it's like,
get a bike and get up every morning and start early. And then,
and also why I get up every morning and walk before I exercise.
And I just to get sunlight, all this stuff. And all of a sudden, it just like,
it made me, I it's like I, I took,
I went to school to become a better person,
which was weird because that's what the books about the book was about becoming
better at being you.
It's kind of interesting. Well, it's interesting because.
You become a better Dave Rubin.
Well, I mean, I've, I've done it. You know what I mean?
What you're going through right now is where I was a year ago.
You'll get to the perfect place Greg, come on and I'm going to help.
I'm going to help you get there. Um, but it's, it,
it is kind of interesting because you wrote the book,
obviously before the pandemic, then you add this part about the pandemic,
but yeah.
What you were writing about and sort of getting your life together really kind
of is what you're trying to show for other people. But that kind of reminds me,
you wrote a piece on Fox news.com about a year ago,
about how people can educate themselves outside the
system. You can learn from Jordan Peterson,
you can go on YouTube and learn from biologists and chemists and all of those
things. Does that strike you? The fact that young people still,
even now, as we watch colleges collapse,
does it seem just completely crazy to you that they're still putting all that
money in on that experiment?
There needs to be okay. Okay.
So there's that old experiment that we see failing,
and it looks like the pandemic is going to push it online and elsewhere.
And then here is the perfect thing,
which is to have no shows like yours or YouTube,
anything on YouTube,
like you getting a biology class from Bret Weinstein or getting a philosophy
class with Jordan Peterson.
But th th the PR the instructors have to be really good.
It can't just be like YouTube where you're like, I get,
I get stuck in a YouTube black hole looking for, um, guitar instruction.
And so it's like how to play rockabilly guitar. So I hit that.
It's 30 minutes and the guides talking for eight minutes and it's like any,
he's just talking and he's holding his guitar. And it's like, I can't do this.
I need like somebody who's an instructor.
And I think that's the only missing point. Cause you have the,
you have the vehicle, you have YouTube,
you've got the internet and you have the desire, the people to want to do this.
You have the pandemic that is forcing people in this direction.
All that's missing is the PR the stylistic
charismatic instructor.
And I go back to Peloton every time pellet would Peloton did to gyms
is what instructors are going to do to college.
So I no longer need to go to a gym again,
because the Peloton instructor is so amazing,
so smart and so authentic. And,
and I love this girl, Hannah Frankston, she's British.
I get up every morning and she gets me on that bike. And she,
she and I it's what she's done is she's taken the product and she's
delivered it to you in the best way possible.
That's the way there has to be colleges that start up with that model that says,
okay, you need great professors. And they gotta be funny. They gotta be smart.
They gotta be not bad. Looking. Everybody in Peloton is great looking.
And they're funny. And, and, uh,
and so I think that's the Peloton model for education is going to be the
solution for all of this. And I'm not thinking, I think that Scott Adams talked,
he said this to me before in an interview that it's like,
this is the step that's necessary is to get likable, talented,
persuasive people, to be the instructor.
And so now you're going to get those people leaving these colleges,
but there has to be something to come to and it's gotta be like Jordan Peterson
teaches, uh, introduction to, uh, apologetics or.
Or whatever.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.